hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on the foreigner again
and welcome back I made a video like
this over a year ago and that was around
the release of season 5 so after this
video we had season 6 through 10 which
had loads of changes new characters
weapons armor new game modes new
factions of characters and a whole load
more which is why I wanted to do a year
3 edition and cover a majority of the
things I missed some of them I won't be
able to cover like peacekeepers face
being unmasked and no boo she's face
being a mess since I don't have those
armors since I'm not high enough with
them but we will go over a lot of
different things that came into this
game and they look absolutely phenomenal
if you haven't seen the first video
it'll be at the end of this video at the
end card or it'll be down in the
description below or in the top right in
the eye as soon as I say that we cover
more the beginning stuff and really get
to go delve deep into what is really
happening the fire looks like orange
squares and all this other [ __ ] and
me seeing my reaction of clay for the
first time it looks really cool but as
usual we got to start from the basics so
here's the game on extreme settings from
just the in-game menu very normal and
very completely understandable it
actually looks like a very beautiful
game once you see how bad we can turn
this now we're gonna turn this into the
lowest settings possible in game a
little bit choppy but we can definitely
do a little bit better with this so
let's make the resolution 5 by 4 first
so we can really get people to wince and
the game is technically fullscreen in
here except locked on the bars or a lot
thicker and the HUD is all squished you
can also swap the 21 by 9 which is the
exact same thing just in a different
direction but personally I like the
first one a lot more but we've only just
begun so a lot of people my first video
wanted a tutorial on how to do this so
accredit to the low spec gamer here
tastes way better approach on this then
I'm going to explain it so I'll leave
his video down in the description as
well but first you must be on PC and you
must have an Nvidia graphics card it's
uncertain if this can actually work for
any AMD Radeon type graphics cards but
there might be a possibility you could
check the comments below in his video
that I linked down in the description
but I know that this works perfectly
with the Nvidia graphics card because
once you're done you have to open up a
program called Nvidia profile inspector
if you don't have it you can easily
download it and then search for fallen
or at the top and then change these
settings super sampling was non disabled
so we're gonna have to change that to
replay mode all I believe is the name
texture filtering a load bias DX value
was set to plus zero with a bunch of
other [ __ ] zeros so change that to
what's shown on screen which is zero X
zero zero zero zero zero zero seven
eight and then I also changed the
resolution on my monitor
not just in game to 640 by 480 P and
here's our what those settings did so
right now we're within the settings I
haven't seen this [ __ ] in so long so
hopefully nothing has changed I'm really
excited to see what happened cuz the
last time I didn't actually change the
resolution they're just the picture
looked like [ __ ] I believe if the the
intro cutscene should actually look a
little bit different you can kind of see
the choppiness in the picture it's
nothing too crazy the game actually the
trailer actually looks pretty [ __ ]
nice with it if we go and try to skip
this with my big-ass little pointer here
if we skip it we can go and actually see
what's in game and I am super excited as
you could tell the shit's already
bugging out but yeah if I remember
correctly I believe it had like some
runescape graphics I mean runescape
looks really cool but I remember if it
looked absolutely bugging out and stuff
and it was just over there
this probably looks 10 times is worse on
your screen than mine mine is
technically full screen that yours
should not be so all the text that's
moving here is actually perfectly fine
for me but I believe when I was testing
the recording this is actually
completely pixelated so if we go over
here to the the player map we you can't
even do it I can't even tell what the
[ __ ] is going on all right we gotta
definitely go into a duel and see how
this [ __ ] plays out in game so your boy
avi obviously we got to pick gladiator I
mean come on like if this ain't the
best-looking gladiator that you've seen
in game I don't know what you've been
seeing rough now the main objective is
to try to win around if not win the
whole game and here's a I can't [ __ ]
do this video man holy [ __ ] let's try to
win this game I don't I think it's the
game is absolutely bugging out cuz it's
really hard to tell but at least on my
point of view it looks like T on D has
three bars of health like shinobi's and
that's obviously not the case I think he
has like four or five
he looks like he has a lot of like a
really low amount of health you know we
hate those dude it don't matter what
[ __ ] resolution man it don't matter
what resolution were on I will still
deflect your ass yeah I'ma be completely
honest with you I can't tell if this
dude is saying thanks or good flight
it's very hard to tell right now that's
the game that's the game dude I'm the
best player alive bro all right
don't even try to come within my realm
okay I can handle these graphics or
anything that you throw at me now that's
pretty bad but we can definitely go even
deeper with this one didn't really
change [ __ ] if I'm being honest with you
yeah so seeing is like what I talked
about before that these changes really
didn't change anything super crazy I was
looking for more of the bigger changes
like the clay models instead of it met
just have maybe may had like minut
effects maybe some shadows or [ __ ] like
that but you finally get into what I
wanted to do is I want to go over some
of the stuff that we got after I
released that video seasons 6 through 10
we had new executions signature emotes
the new illustrious stuff which I'ma be
honest with you I'm super excited to see
how the bird and the ghost looks so I'm
gonna be completely honest with you I
haven't seen anything of this so the
first thing we gotta do is check
Shinobi's execution shadow of death and
that looks actually atrocious you see
the thing with that whole execution is
that you're supposed to you're supposed
to not see him and it's clearly obvious
that you can see him and that
decapitation looked uh turn our [ __ ]
as a quick little update as we can tell
as we saw before black prior absolutely
looking spiffy like if we go over to
hito Kira she looks just as stupid I
can't really even tell what the hell's
going on with her right now but a lot of
blander textures she's got going on here
so the one thing I definitely wanted to
do was check the woolen outfits for
season 9 of the illustrious stuff
because back in season 9 for the
illustrious outfits we ended up getting
and the Phoenix one that comes with the
woollen is I bet basically on fire and
fire in this texture pack or whatever
the hell you want to call this is super
buggy and looks like squares so I have
to see what this looks like Oh what the
[ __ ] is that as you could tell all
Austria's outfits look absolutely stupid
there's no textures in these at all the
apollyon mask you know actually that
doesn't look too bad I'll give that one
the pass some of these which I have to
check out if we go to the Knights I know
they have the Oh genius or it's the cola
toriel one weird weird times in for
honor when we had those masks I'm not
really sure what was going on in their
head but I'm gonna zoom in a little bit
I mean it's not too bad most of the
stuff what colors actually doesn't look
as bad as I thought but it's still very
very garbage this shield by the way my
shield looks nothing like that I will
show you I'll show a picture of what it
actually looks like and that is nowhere
near what that [ __ ] was supposed to look
like and the one thing is that when you
change your color is that the color is
just one flat color it even changes
where your stomach is supposed to be
gladiator stomach is actually supposed
to be showing in this color and it looks
kind of like this red blob was just
painted on it and just because I'm an
[ __ ] we're gonna totally ruin this
signature of Nobu she'd the newest one
she got whimsical we're gonna completely
ruin this with its very disgusting
textures which I mean if you play
runescape being actually that bad of a
texture honestly now one thing I
definitely want to check out is the
effects we had a hell of a lot of
effects added into the game for example
we have the Tesla door from season 10
arcade which kind of looks the same as
they did before
a lot of weird blood and red going
around here really really creepy as well
a lot of just a yellow blob of stuff oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
nevermind I'm a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] I
forgot that rep 70 wasn't in effect it
was actually an emote so here it is that
looks stupid honestly though I got to
admit the ghosts don't look that
different
and since it's been so long since I've
made this video again I feel like we
should definitely return to one of the
newer game modes that was out breach and
see how the commander and everything
else in that game looks hi we made it to
the commander and we get to do one well
if there's something we'd take away from
this video I think this was definitely a
learning experience you know we've been
seeing all the newest stuff we'd
remastered an older video we could see
all the juicy [ __ ] that we missed over
the fast five seasons hold on not these
hell on let me fix that real quick
that's better
hey guys it's gonna be the end of the
baits I hope you guys did enjoy like the
V if he did subscribe for new I cover
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the Patrick's and leaks if you
want to be kept up today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update then
please they subscribe to the channel I
don't even know if I'll ever make a
third part of this video if the game
keeps going for like another three years
we'll make a third part at this video I
promise you that but yeah as of right
now this is probably going to be the end
of this little miniseries we had since I
don't want to keep doing this every
single season yeah thanks for watching
hopefully you guys did enjoy a little
remaster of some beautiful content it
was such a fun time making this video
yeah peace out guys have a great day and
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]